this season of anime has a couple good
shows but from the start the one that
truly stood out to me was
to your eternity and it clearly has done
the same to everyone else who's watched
it considering it's already jumped up to
spot number 43
on the best anime of all time on my
anime list with only
2 episodes aired stand back my hero with
the passing of winter 2021
so has the season of sequels dr stone
re-zero attack on titan we've moved on
to a phase in 2021 where the best anime
are the new
up-and-comers and i honestly couldn't be
happier about it
to your eternity is spearheading 2021's
movement into an age of recovery and new
beginnings for anime as we usher in this
new decade
and again let me remind you it's only
two episodes in
but dear lord it is magnificent today
i've decided to do a super deep analysis
of
yes only the first episode first 25
minutes of this show that has already
left such a resounding impact on me
as we know from anime already with short
movies such as
into the forest of firefly's light which
is a 45 minute tear jerker
the power that such a short animated
work can have
the attachments that you can build in a
period of time shorter than
most of us spend on the toilet in a
shorter period of time than it takes to
realize that
boku no pico isn't in fact the wholesome
family anime that your demented friend
said it would be
wait what was i talking about i'm
breaking down each part of this 25
minute sob story
this inspirational tale journey of the
soul whatever you want to call this
piece of art
how it dives into the tragic cycle of
insanity the feelings of hopelessness
one can experience
but also on the other side of the
spectrum the permanence of hope itself
and how this episode ends perfectly full
circle in a poetic way that
makes you question what you yourself are
doing with your life
yeah you what are you doing with your
life why aren't you subscribed
are you part of that 97 help me out show
some support
like and subscribe and let me roll my
intro
[Music]
to your eternity begins with the
introduction of an orb
one that to quote are soothing and
soft-spoken omniscient narrator
captures the reflections of many things
and changes in response
it first begins as a rock and as it gets
warmer it takes the form of moss
and after a wolf appears and dies upon
said moss
it takes that form it learns what
consciousness is
how to walk pain feelings of cold scent
the temptation and characteristics of
the world are felt
and the wolf eventually wanders upon an
abandoned village
with a lone survivor who is revealed to
have owned the wolf
of course the wolf he owned is now dead
but we see our orb
our moss or wolf or whatever he is at
this point
replace joanne which is the original
pet's name
and initially the show makes this
environment this cozy little home of the
unnamed boy to be
almost like an untouched haven the
narrator says how if the dog could speak
it would have said it wanted to stay
here forever
but alas as we move on to the next day
we see the sad truth of it all
that the boy's family and the rest of
the village aside from the elderly who
were unable to
made the trek south to paradise a place
where the only food isn't just
fish from a nearby pond but fruit and
meat and vegetables
but it's been five years since they left
and the boy still holds out hope that
they will return someday
and thus the boy spends his every day
simply living
hoping that they've returned to retrieve
him as he bides his time with his trusty
wolf on his side
and i have to make an important note
here about things i've noticed so far in
this episode because it's already clear
by this point that the boy
is legitimately insane in some shaper
way
listen when joanne first returns the boy
is ecstatic as he hasn't seen the dog in
a while
but as he tries to feed joanne who of
course is unfamiliar with the concept of
eating
at all because it used to be moss he
says how joanne probably doesn't like
the food because it's not horned your
milk which i guess joan liked
and that the last horn deer died over a
year ago
wait what if the last time horn deer
milk was available was over a year ago
and this is the first time you take note
of the wolf's lack of appetite for
anything else how long was joanne gone
was this wolf gone for over a year why
was the wolf gone why
didn't the boy go searching for his only
friend
and i think we get some form of an
answer soon after when he mistakenly
thinks someone has returned home
when in fact his tripwire is just
signifying that a fish got caught
but fish is all the boy eats
is this system set in place in a way
that every time a fish is caught he
thinks
someone has returned why doesn't he fix
the wire so that it distinguishes
between
food and a person coming home which is a
way bigger occurrence
is this what keeps him tied down to this
place this fleeting feeling of hope that
comes and goes constantly
doing this over and over isn't that what
insanity is
but you feel bad for the kid burdens
with this mental illness or at least
this self-construed hope that he has
he draws the faces of all the villagers
on his walls to make sure they're never
forgotten
and he actually makes the unexpected
decision to finally go south and find
his paradise
with joanne by his side of course but
something to note before he leaves
is that he's already drawn his and
joan's face on the wall of the people
who he hopes
won't ever be forgotten an ominous
foreboding to how this journey will end
on his travels with joanne we quickly
see the cold taking a toll on his body
visually
as he follows these rocks with an arrow
on them presumably signifying the path
to paradise
but on the way he falls through ice and
into the cold depths of a pond
soaking himself and even if that weren't
enough to take a toll on his body
he's injured his leg too out in the
freezing cold
wet and injured i mean by the halfway
point of this episode we already know
that the boy
isn't making out of this episode alive
which makes all the rest more sad
as you know of his impending fate as his
mind and body
slowly fall apart he continues traveling
and finds the remains of his village
but it's nothing but graves and broken
wagons indicating that they too
could not make the journey to paradise
the arrows that once signified hope are
now crossed out
showing that all of that hope is gone
and here we see him almost lose his mind
as
everything he's believed for his whole
life for at least the past five years
falls apart they were never gonna come
back he was never talking to a wolf it
was
all in his head which we of course sadly
have known from the start as a third
party watcher
perhaps what the narrator said at the
beginning that the wolf would have liked
to stay in that home forever
was the only paradise that really
existed
just the boy and joanne living life
the boy said at one point that the
paradise in the south will be the
quote-unquote
ultimate freedom but we as watchers and
in the modern day can only help but
think was the boy not already free
just existing day by day no obligations
but to himself
and the small world that surrounds him
what is freedom what should we make of
our lives
these are the kinds of questions that
only the first episode of the show
raises
and thus the boy decides to return back
abandon his journey
and live once again in that hopeless
home
his fever gets worse his injury takes
its toll and as the boy gives joan the
last of his food he crawls to his chair
sitting among the many faces of the
villages he once knew and loved
imbuing his last dying wish in joanne
to remember him forever perhaps the boy
knew
from the moment he drew his face on the
wall that there was no paradise
but he wanted to end his life on his own
terms knowing that he tried to do
something he could be remembered by
and now as joan takes on the form of the
boy after that stimulation
he goes on to this journey to live and
feel and do things
what the boy would have wanted to do
remembering him
all the way and now that i've covered
the plot there's a few points that i
want to mention that make this episode
so much more immaculate
first which is really just a small note
that i found cool was the fact that both
johan
the original wolf and the boy died of
the same leg injury
we don't know how or why joanne died out
there or
ran away from the boy and the home that
was so nice
but perhaps joanne felt the same way and
was searching for some kind of hope
but regardless the two partners who were
always together died together as well
and i just thought that was absolutely
beautiful
what i also think is great about
two-year eternity is the subtleties in
which the orb learns
new things of course there are obvious
parts where he learns to eat
food or whatever the narrator says over
top but there are things beneath the
surface that makes the orb's growth
as an existence on this planet more
natural more incredible
how did the orb know to return to the
boy's home after taking the form of the
wolf
sure i mean it could have wandered and
eventually found it
but there's also things such as
mimicking the boy's actions when eating
pulling on him when he fell checking to
see if he's alive at the end of the
episode
you see the orb develop emotions without
it having to be said
at all what began as a rock a completely
non-living existence is now the sole
source of hope for this boy
is carrying on his will as it learns
what it means to be alive
and that is what two-year eternity is
all about about what
living means the eternal struggle of
humans and other life-forms to make
something out of it all
more than just existing who knows
perhaps the narrator is god himself and
the orb is his way of seeing what
humans have made of themselves who are
originally at the beginning of time
simple replicas of god's image similar
to the orb
just lifeless beings how the earth has
crafted these humans into living
breathing and feeling things and what it
would be like to feel
all of those things from the very start
once again
the orb is living through humanity and
witnessing the depths of emotion that
people feel
and i'm 100 ready for two-year eternity
to take me through this endless journey
of
sheer exploration into the human mind
and
i'm uh i'm 100 ready to let the tears
flow too
did you think of the first episode and
the second as well i guess
it honestly just blew me out of the park
so much so that i couldn't even wait
till the series was over to make a video
about it
be sure to check it out if you haven't
already though i suppose if you're this
far into the video and haven't seen the
show yet i uh
i kind of spoiled the first episode for
you regardless though
check it out as always this has been the
anime culture corner i hope you enjoyed
the video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga and character
analyses
you